[Musique]
à la bergerie nationale on vit dans le
far west depuis le début des vacances
mélanie vous avez galoper jusqu'à
rambouillet alors rencontre des cowboys
et des indiens
c'est une tradition à à rambouillet
chaque année pour les vacances de la
toussaint les cowboys et les indiens
débat pour proposer tout un tas
d'activités alors les vacances sont
quasi terminés mais le départ pour le
far west est encore possible puisque les
animations dure jusqu'à dimanche
il faut bien sûr choisir son camp l'idée
c'est qu'on a mis en place des ateliers
créatifs où ils peuvent se déguiser
comme un cow-boy ou comme un indien
il ya aussi des petites initiation au
tir à l'arc que tient à la carabine
il ya aussi une initiation au cheval
mécanique et le clou de l'après-midi
l'attaqué de la diligence
ouais c'est le rendez vous à ne pas
manquer c'est là où le choix du camp est
fondamental parce qu'ils ont plus il ya
une épreuve de force qui est proposé un
tir à la corde pour voir qui gagne mais
bien sûr ça se joue en équipe et les
animations ont débuté il ya bientôt deux
semaines mais les cowboys sont en
mauvaise posture à cholet à la bergerie
ce mardi et le score était déjà sans
appel pour les indiens c'est cette
victoire à troyes pour les indiens lors
la bergerie a besoin de renfort s'il ya
des supers corus est l'occasion et c'est
aussi l'occasion d'apprendre à danser la
country la danse des cow boys et surtout
il ya une nouveauté cette année un
cimetière de quoi frissonner quelques
instants
l'entrée est libre et les activités ce
franck les parents et les indiens sont
partout ils ont aussi envahi versailles
ils ont carrément enlever still have à
la mairie puisque avec sans doute le
plus célèbre d'entre eux incertains il
ya karim le petit indien a été créée par
derib il ya 48 ans et l'expo se termine
elle aussi dimanche en 2 novembre et
vous pourrez découvrir comment le
dessinateur suisse crée les chevaux la
technique pour dessiner un cheval c'est
surtout d'en avoir monté pour pouvoir
les connaître les avoir senti savoir
comment des muscles bouge quand on
galope canton 30 d'intentions d'un
obstacle
et comme j'ai vécu pendant 30 ans je
pense que je suis à même drainé dessinée
correctement alors deux rendez-vous pour
partir de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
mais camille êtes plutôt cobayes moyens
à les indiens sans hésitation je pense
qu'on peut alors aller leur prêter main
forte ce week end
merci beaucoup en tout cas mélanie pour
ce voyage en plein western